I'm telling you it isn't going to work
look I know that video game movies have
had a rough go of it up to this point
but i think we are finally in the
ballpark ballpark are you on crack these
movies might as well be playing hockey
up until now guys for your own safety
stay away from the sports metaphors
listen look just look at what is
actually moving forward right now
uncharted easily the most cinematic game
series ever made and this is a big
screen slam dunk uncharted may have told
that story well but put it on the big
screen and it's just another Indiana
Jones naka you know it fine assassin's
creed tell me that is not going to be
awesome it isn't I'll give you
Assassin's Creed is visually stunning
but the story is a convoluted mess
excellent imagery did not save Silent
Hill pyramid head for the fail well even
if you were right what you aren't you
will be eating crow once they get around
to making the diablo movie never going
to happen and even if it does it won't
work the first game had no storyline at
all and i'm sorry no matter how many
times you email blizzard your spec
script they're not gonna make it shut up
it's a brilliant script besides a loser
story gives more room for a filmmaker
with vision to come in and really do
something with it filmmakers with vision
do not make video game movies and yet
Duncan Jones is making world of warcraft
they're not going to give him the
freedom he needs to translate a story
that Bay all right mr. Spielberg what
game would you adapt none of them look
at the stories objectively there isn't a
single game out there that cinema ready
no storytelling in a game is much
different from storytelling in a movie
the interactive nature of a game
dictates a certain experience take the
game out of an interactive
text and the stories are all lame there
isn't a single game you can convince me
would ever work mm our crime journey
littlebigplanet Oh call me Kathy you
bear animated wait what you put a
visually arresting game like a commie in
the hands of studio jibley or give
littlebigplanet to Pixar and I promise
you masterpieces he's speechless smart
the time in the date damn it and I
extend my lead have you guys been
competing over who can render me
speechless more maybe how long has this
been going on 13 years sounds right and
what's the score 724 I really do talk
too much don't and how are we can we how
that nope that was the finished thought
damn
you